meilleur souvenir
je pense que c'est la première fois que
si lille et ses équipes ont offert une
maison à une famille qui était dans la
galère est ce qu'on peut faire tomber là
bas je sais vous plaît
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
j'ai été avec les potes ont regardé le
prince des voleurs et les prime à la
partie et j'ai chéri lavaud qui ne
pouvait plus arrêter de poulets quoi
c'était hyper les mouvements c'est la
première fois que soyez quelque chose
comme ça à la télé en direct en plus la
famille était là il était sur le plateau
j'ai de l'émotion du petit caca dias et
que j'allais me marier le meilleur dîner
de sa vie city ville venez manger chez
eux quand ils sont à la maison fin
c'était c'était génial ça cctp que moi
je j'ai même chez le cochon que je
défendrai toute ma vie
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il mourra
alors mon pire souvenir j'ai géré en
tant que téléspectatrice de dpn et ça
fait pas très longtemps que je suis dans
l'émission mais un truc qui m'a marqué
c'est le départ de thierry morin j'avais
prévu de faire quelque chose cette
semaine et vous me donnez l'occasion de
le faire ce soir c'est ma dernière
mission de tpm p non mais sérieux et mp
définitivement il personne n'a compris
parce que moi on en avait parlé à
personne et il est parti il est parti en
laissant tourner dans l'incompréhension
dont j'avais peur qu'il aille mal
j'avais peur qu'ils soient mal avec les
amis et j'attends qu'ils sont malades et
peut-il il était grave alors 17 vannes a
pris puisque je suis pas du tout court
je sais que vous n'êtes pas ou quoi
c'est vous et donc je m'en vais voilà
c'était bien mais non mais non tu peux
pas partir comme ça mais oui c'est vrai
je vous dis je vous embrasse très très
fort et leur métier alors attendez la
fin des missions vous n'avez pas partir
dans les denrées vue de le faire de
toute façon par dont la caméra les où
j'avais prévu d'être victimes de la
terrible et donc je vous dis mais
asseyez-vous des moules lattes et je
mens non mais vraiment j'avais prévu de
le faire donc je vous aime et vous
donnez nous des je vous remercie
vraiment de tout ce que vous avez et
surtout je n'avais pas envie qu'il
quitte l'émission donc c'est vrai que je
me prends comme un déchirement on y
trouvait des choses de façon très
exacerbée
ça m'a beaucoup marqué
[Musique]